cette thématique qui nous réunit c'est
donc le patrimoine culturel matériel
l'exemple de l'église
saint-pierre-aux-liens de bellefontaine
que j'ai eu l'occasion de dany mais dont
j'ai eu l'occasion d'animer de présenter
de proposer une visite guidée
donc c'est un bâtiment qui a reçu le
label architecture contemporaine
remarquable au titre dieu ce qu'elle est
en pierre entièrement taillé à la main
elle regorge d'éléments qui sont
répertoriés au patrimoine culturel de
france
donc j'ai pu présenter ce bâtiment et
mon approche magnin comment raphaël
concept fait vivre cet élément du
patrimoine bellifontain notre culture
martiniquaise est extrêmement riche
riche dans toutes ses dimensions qu'elle
soit naturelle matériels immatériels et
cetera notre société bâtie sur un
certain nombre de valeurs qui tendent à
se perdre avec la modernisation ou
peut-être pas se perdre mais se
distiller et raphaël concept à au delà
des décomptes des concepts que ce soit
les coudes scène la tambouille soupe
tout ce qu'on peut mettre en place comme
action on s'appuie sur un socle de
valeurs que sont le système d'entrée de
lits en âge comme on dit les valeurs
familiales puisque nous sommes une
structure familiale et on s'appuie
dessus pour prouver que notre identité
martiniquaise nos us et coutumes notre
bon ajouté de 12/100 fait la chaleur
qu'on retrouve chez nous sans compter
notre gastronomie extraordinaire peuvent
créer de la richesse économique et des
emplois et à ce titre c'est une bonne
pratique
alors je pense que la plus belle des
choses que ça m'a apporté c'est de
réaliser que souvent on entend parler de
l'union européenne de ce que la
martinique fait partie de l'europe en
tant que région ultrapériphérique mais
ça nous semble tellement éloignés et
voilà ce projet punch réunissait un
certain nombre de pays de un certain
nombre de représentants nous avons eu
des contacts directs avec des citoyens
de l'europe des acteurs comme moi même
dans avec des statuts différents
est ce que j'ai réalisé qui m'a vraiment
touché c'est que cette dynamique car
raphaël concept est véritablement
innovantes
remarquable a été remarquée justement on
a eu des échanges après pour approfondir
comment en fait on fait ce travail comme
on met en lumière comment valorise notre
culture locale au service de la création
d'activité économique et d'emplois